- Who doesn't own a big backyard
like that
and not have one car in it?
That's just a waste.
Oh, look at that.
Look at that monster.
Holy crap, that's like a
deuce and a half on steroids.
That is neat.
Hey, can we check that out?
Pull over.
Pull over?
Watch this.
Stay there truck.
Yo, that thing's wicked.
That's Danny's flavor.
Yeah.
Nice, dude.
Oh, that is nice.
Kevin and I are out searching
for a quick flip for the shop.
While this car
doesn't look like it
needs any work by
us or anyone else,
I still want to check it out.
- How you doing?
I'm Kevin.
- I'm Chrome.
Nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you.
Yeah, man.
Man, '53.
That is laid out.
The 1953 Chevys
were the precursor
to the famous Trifives.
Since the '53s weren't
as popular or as valuable
as stock cars, they were a
favorite among low riders
and custom builders
to completely
customize from the ground up.
They're so popular
in this scene,
that even Hot Wheels made
a '53 Chevy lowrider toy.
Man, this is a bitching car.
Obviously, it's been chopped.
How much did you chop it?
The guy-- because
I got her like this.
- Really?
- Yeah.
- Lucky you, man.
- I know.
I saw it and I was like,
wow, it's got potential.
You know, it needed glass.
It didn't have the white walls.
I changed the grill out.
- This is a good chop.
- I know.
They did--
- It's really good.
I think they did pretty good.
Was this piece here,
this skirt piece?
- Yeah.
- That is freaking--
That's the rock chip guard.
I love that piece.
You have to, because the car
is black and you lay it out,
now it just blends
into the asphalt.
What motor you got in it?
350.
Nice.
It's pretty-- pretty decent.
I mean, man, we were
flying down here.
Oh, I'll bet, man.
Nice lines.
Who did the striping on them?
I guess whoever,
the guy I got it from,
he must have had
somebody do those.
It's cool.
You know, it was
one of those, it was
like a diamond in the rough.
Right?
You know, I saw the
potential and I jumped on it.
Did you find it
in Southern Cal?
Yeah, it was San Diego.
There's a lot of
shops in San Diego,
like backyard shops
in San Diego doing
all this stuff all the time.
And then they unload it.
I'm going to put
a sale sign on it.
Are you really?
Yeah.
What's the magic number on it?
- I need 30.
- 30?
- 30, yeah.
- I can't argue with that.
What transmission
are you running in it?
- 700.
- Oh.
Get out of here.
Really?
I'm telling you,
we were flying.
That's 350, 700R4, damn.
Cruise it.
- Yeah.
- It was smooth.
Bro, 30 all day long.
30 all day long.
- All day.
All day long.
Man, that chop top
Chevy was beautiful
and definitely worth
$30,000, but by no means,
is it a quick flip for us.
So we're going to
keep on looking.
Got chops on this
one, man, seriously.
- I know, bro.
- This is a cool ass ride, man.
Pleasure meeting
you guys, man.
Back at you, dude.
Cool, brother.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
The price is good,
but not fall off
the back of the truck price.